[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue d'anciens en
parler sport c'est la rentrée le premier
numéro de l'année mais rassurez-vous
nous vous ne serez pas dépaysés on ne
change pas la recette de l'émission il y
aura comme d'habitude des analyses des
débats et des duels enragé avec nos
chroniqueurs ils sont quatre autour de
cette table
aujourd'hui présentation on commence à
ma droite la rentrée toujours son moment
préféré pendant les vacances il s'ennuie
il avait hâte de revenir sur ce plateau
le capitaine
ils viennent du jarrier piste 1 au club
de vélizy 78 avec lui aujourd'hui
bonjour mon lit d'anne joyal vous avez
humilié un petit peu de temps mais je
vais concentrer sur autre chose
akram travail excusez moi enfin
travailler tout le temps voilà on se
fait la rentrée vous êtes content d'être
ici super g plaisir c'était un petit peu
long cet été sans vous
c'était pareil pour moi on passe de
l'autre côté à musique
elle n'a pas dormi de la nuit elle avait
tellement hâte de revenir sur ce plateau
et de revoir les copains notre
ambassadrice de charme la très sportive
la pole dance hausse de versailles
hélène avec nous je suis ravi de revenir
j'attendais j'attendais septembre défilé
je me disais mais quand est ce qu'on
reprend et ça y est vous avez quand même
dormir un petit peu cette nuit c'est à
dire c'était compliqué mais je suis sur
le pied de grue depuis 6 heures là
j'attends j'attends j'attends parfait on
passe de l'autre côté à musique ça fait
des semaines qui on me demande la date
du 1er à 6 ans par les spores de la
saison un événement qui ne manqueraient
pour rien au monde il est donc venu
comme d'habitude armé de ses anecdotes
le gladiateur de versailles pierre
chevallier sera avec nous pendant une
heure salut michael
comment allez-vous pour jour des routes
ça va super bien le cartable est prêt
les stylos sont taillés pour être prêt
bleu métal c'est nickel du de la rentrée
on termine de l'autre côté musique on ne
le présente plus c'est notre chouchou et
en particulier celui d'hélène la légende
lui
notre super chroniqueurs spécialistes
rugby coach jean miss ex-entraîneur de
plaisir ou fait l'honneur de venir
encore une nouvelle fois sur ce plateau
quand allez-vous gens très bien amicale
sera très très bien vous avez réussi à
vous libérer en pleine coupe du monde de
rugby
ah oui mais voilà on est important ici
nous sommes neuf à la télé mais comme
vous aviez le choix de la date
j'ai préfet j'ai préféré venir là
aujourd'hui c'est tôt le matin donc
savoir là c'est tout mon savoir je le
comprends alors avant de passer au thème
de l'émission un mot d'une légende carl
lewis
le célèbre athlète qui a remporté neuf
médailles d'or olympique et dix
médailles aux championnats du monde
aujourd'hui âgé de 58 ans était au début
du mois de septembre dans les yvelines
il a rencontré à clairefontaine les
joueurs de l'équipe de france de
football
l'ancien sportif est également allé voir
les pistards de l'équipe de france au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines comme on peut le voir sur ces
images lors d'un événement organisé par
son sponsor une réaction je trouve cette
table bien dujarrier très très déçu
parce que ben encore une fois c'est un
jour où ce travail et j'ai eu
l'information
impossible de me des loyers trop et
sinon sinon je pense qu'une demi-heure
après avoir une information le samedi
matin j'étais au vélodrome pour
rencontrer cette cette légende du sport
parce que pour moi
carl lewis ce sont mes premiers
souvenirs de jeux olympiques avec ce
fameux tourer et tourne enfin ce
concours du saut en longueur voilà
c'était c'était magique c'est c'est
quelque chose qui reste qui reste
imprimée imprimé en nous et voilà oui
j'aurais aimé rencontre pouvoir
rencontrer cette enquête les bruits qui
est connu au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines vous avez pas
eu l'heur l'information un petit peu
avant non pas du tout de toute façon
même s'il a vu avant j'étais en
séminaire je ne pouvais pas me je peux
pas me libérer ses terres occupées ya
dujarrier hélène légende donc voila mais
moi j'ai pas eu d'information dont plus
personne ne me dit rien personne ne me
dit rien voilà genre qu'est ce qui vous
inspire à 15 m carl lewis je rejoins et
rihanna moi je me levais les jeux
olympiques de los angeles en 84 je veux
lever pour garder ses liens formels
suscité hier c'était hier après cimade
un petit peu déçu parce que c'est quand
même le sportif qui prônait le sport
propre
et puis il avoué par il ya quelques
temps qu'ils s'étaient dopés donc fait
qu'il était dopé finalement c'est un peu
ça m'a déçu parce que moi c'est devant
l'athlète
pour moi c'est la référence de
l'athlétisme puis je te mets qu'ils
étaient efficaces et des gars qui
étaient qui était magnifique et se voit
mois seulement le le sportif qui m'a
fait aimer l'esthétisme à l'efb à
l'époque de l'ère des réseaux sociaux et
de la disponibilité de l'information à
toute heure et à tout minutes c'est
quand même assez rare malgré tout de
voir des légendes en vrai c'est vrai
qu'on aurait peut-être pu ou dû avoir
l'info plus tôt pour pouvoir en profiter
mais c'est toujours c'est toujours je
pense en effet le monde même s'il n'est
pas prévu de longue date mais c'est
toujours un événement de voir un
chronométreur monstres sacrés de ce type
là il en reste il ne reste plus des
masses de cette époque là et de pouvoir
les approcher
quel que soit le sujet de la
conversation mais au moins au moins
touchés touché le mythe de près c'est
une chose qui pourrait être qui peut à
mon avis être mémorable dommage qu'on
ait raté ça peut-être qu'il reviendra
dans les yvelines
allez on ne sait jamais l'émission
aujourd'hui nous allons parler de
l'exploit de thomas des rixes jeunes qui
montent eux aussi à traverser à la
marche le plus grand désert de sel au
monde où font également un coup de
projecteur sur le rugby et les nouvelles
règles du placage haut niveau amateur
mais avant de développer ces thèmes
on va parler football
on commence donc par du football début
de saison compliqué pour le strap en
football les trappistes qui sont montés
cette saison en régionale 2 n'ont pas
encore remporté un seul match cette
saison trois matches on regarde les
scores 1 0 à domicile face à houilles 2
à 1 face à poissy 3 à 2 face à champigné
avec deux buts encaissés dans les arrêts
de jeu nous avions interrogé le nouveau
coach de trappes ils nous confient les
objectifs du club cette saison au micro
de nicolas landry l'objectif du club
c'est un maintien facile mais un
maintien facile ça veut dire être
maintenue mars avril
si on est maintenue mars avril ça veut
dire qu'on est en haut donc on verra
bien alors les joueurs pourront
désormais se concentrer sur le résultat
les résultats en championnat car les
trappistes ont été sortis de la coupe de
france au troisième tour face à une
équipe de d1 gretz tournan sur le score
de 6 à 0
le coach a fait légèrement tourner son
effectif il y avait 0 à 0 à la mi-temps
et puis les joueurs ont pris six buts en
seconde période
la question sur ce thème faut-il déjà
condamné trappe
oui ou non vous votez non
oh attendez attendez hélène ne sait pas
encore pour une série non mais le
partager moi j'encourage toujours mais
c'est plus là comment dire les oui oui
mais la dynamique est puisque nos toits
ce qu'ils emploient aussi comme au
l'énergie je fais un pour porter une
équipe même même pour conserver un
niveau on peut pas se dire on verra bien
enfin moi ça me paraît un jour bien oui
mais ça on veut on se maintient
gentiment et bien on verra ça me paraît
un peu léger
pour soutenir et un thonier kiwi moi
alors je condamne pas mais je condamne
pas l'équipe ni la réussite mais je
condamne plus tôt le façon de parler du
coach et de porter l'équipe ça me paraît
un peu léger mais pas son message quand
vous dites que l'on termine c'est
condamner sur la sur la saison passée en
descente défend il a peut-être fait ils
ont peut-être faire un choix un choix de
mettre de côté la cause de la coupe de
france et encore
second scénario alors j'ai le coach
justement c'est plus c'est plus marrant
les mentions au téléphone c'était pas
forcément l'objectif cette année c'était
le maintien forcément la coupe de france
était un bonus dont il a fait un peu
tourner mais pas non plus donc ils ont
ils ont serré on n'a pas fait tourner
tout l'effectif ont fait un choix mais
la saison vient de démarrer
il est aidé ma paraît vraiment entendu 6
à 0 prix en seconde période oui ça c'est
normal mais il a dit de la saison
démarre peut-être bien de là les
enterrer tout de suite il ya un monde où
il ya un monde d'écart
tant pis tant pis pour la coupe de
france mais maintenant ils seront
vraiment bien concentrés sur le
championnat un peu de chance de voir le
stade de france ça c'est sûr quelques
tours à passer quelques tours sur 12 ans
vous avez entendu non mais non monsieur
jo socialement bien sûr essayé et j'ai
bien compris c'est le début de saison
nos campus ils n'ont pas pris des deux
grosses défaites c'est d'un but à chaque
fois
après c'est vrai que le le discours de
l'entraîneur mais c'est un discours que
je réagis devant gautier est arrivé
cette saison
ogunbiyi hilare un plateau riche riche
interdite qui était arrivée l'an dernier
qui a quitté le club au bout d'un an
pour raisons personnelles
il a laissé club avec une montée voilà
mais un très bon résultat espéré depuis
de nombreuses années passent rap c'est
pour ça qu'il ya à ludovic aussi arrive
de versailles pour reprendre l'équipe
avec nous un nouvel effectif
voilà non mais c'est pour ça va vous
faire il s'est quand même le temps de
mettre en place son jeu et ses idées à
ce garçon est encore une fois comme on a
dit je ne vont pas le redira coupe de
france s'est mis de côté mais là sur le
début du championnat
il a pas pris
il a pris juste défaite d'un but quoi
sur les trois premiers matches donc
l'intérêt n'en sait on sait pertinemment
que sports collectifs quel qu'il soit il
faut un temps pour que le jeu soit mise
en place et que l'entraîneur puisse y
mettre sa petite pas de personnel donc
laissons lui le tarn leone doivent
surtout pas les intérêts voix pour moi
ils s'en sortiront
il ya le niveau est également plus
relevé cette année forcément airs de
camp r3 ça joue forcément sur le début
de saison compliqué de l'équipe
oui oui bien sûr que et bien sûr que là
il ya beaucoup de changements pour pour
l'arrivée d'un nouveau coach c'est vrai
que c'est quand même dommage d'avoir
perdu le code de la montée qui qui
aurait pu qui aurait certainement pu
continuer sur le même discours et avec
les mêmes les mêmes
elle est la muse et annick voilà là
c'est peut-être un petit coup au moral
pour pour les pour les pour les joueurs
il faut il faut encaisser tout ça et
puis et puis voilà prendre les matches
un président commençait à prendre des
points et puis voilà comme dit comme dit
jean sage ou à un but à chaque fois deux
buts dans le dernier sur dans les arènes
je vais 2 1 lors du dernier jeu et son
attrapé trois victoires et deux 2e en 4
minutes et donc
donc ça veut ça veut bien dire que voilà
à rien tous ces matches pouvaient
tourner en faveur d'un match nul et et
donc ça ne faisait plus la tpu même
résultat donc va falloir se réveiller va
falloir mettre un coup d un coup de
collier pour pour remonter tout ça et
puis et puis bon courage et on va aller
on va les surveiller mais en effet après
une montée
les éléments sont pas les plus les plus
les plus évidentes chercheur médias
seulement talent à surveiller la
dimension mentale parce que s'ils
perdent s'y perdre comme ça sur le plus
tôt et sur les deuxièmes deuxième
mi-temps est sûre plus tôt fin de match
c'est juste une gestion des matches une
gestion gestion de la compétition et en
os mettre le pied sur le ballon et puis
et puis réussir à sortir un résultat
changement aussi et peut-être aussi un
manque d'un monde de physique un kiki
petit peut être là et se faire ressentir
sur les dix dernières minutes d'un match
à ce niveau là si la préparation a été
un peu tardive ou reprise un peu tardive
cet été moi je me souviens pas les eaux
avoir vu les mecs les mecs ça allait
aller courir faire des footings pendant
pendant toute la boule de poils de chien
coûte de foot de palaiseau gelé je les
croise je les croise tous les ans au
mois d'août faire défaire les footings
commencer la prépa physique et ça
m'étonne toujours parce que c'est pas
des gros niveau c'est à peu près à peu
près la même chose du r2 du r duet reins
etc
et je me dis les mecs voilà les mecs se
sont quand même impliqué dans le
dans leur sport et et je trouve ça je
trouve ça bien
dernière question à quel moment il
faudra s'inquiéter gens à la fin non il
est certainement mais il est certain que
si la spirale des défaites continue
là il faudra commencer à s'inquiéter
parce qu'on le sait pertinemment une
fois qu'on est pris dans cette nouvelle
mauvaise spirale
il est très difficile de relever la tête
et de de pouvoir avoir un discours
positif et pour renverser la vapeur
c'est que de plus en plus compliqué ça
on le sait là il fait 3 défaites sur
fromage
il faut très vite qu'il redresse et 24
défaites oui avec la coupe de france
mais je pense je parle moi parce que je
pense qu'ils se concentrent sur le
championnat
moi je mets je mets un coup de france de
côté mais bon c'est vrai qu'il y ait
quand même mentalement et moralement
mais là il faut il faut vraiment sur le
prochain match c'est parce qu'ils jouent
mais j'espère qu'ils jouent pas une
grosse équipe justement donc pour
l'instant trap est bon dernier de sa
poule et les joueurs de ludovic gauthier
affronteront le dimanche 6 octobre cosmo
taverny et l'adedy juste au dessus juste
au dessus voilà voilà
c'est ce qu'ils veulent entrer
déclencheur c'est ce match qui doit être
déclencheur il faut impérativement qu'il
eux qui le gagne parce que la cip s'ils
perdent encore ce match contre une
équipe qui va qui rivalisent pour ne pas
descendre
là par contre le doute va s'installer ce
sera difficile de renverser la on leur
souhaite évidemment une victoire au oui
lancer leur saison à parler rugby c'est
la petite nouveauté cette année les
équipes seniors du sky rugby de monty
l'aube retenues ont fusionné pour donner
naissance à l'union rugby 178 pour leur
premier match dans le championnat
honneur
ils ont emporté à domicile contre le red
star sur le score de 32 à 13
les débuts qui ont évidemment ravi le
nouvel entraîneur de l'équipe saignant
l'écoutent au micro de nicolas dont 10
on se bouffe et de plaisir parce qu'on
porte un petit peu dans l'inconnu re
savait pas où on en était on a bien
travaillé depuis un mois un mois et demi
et puis on voit que que l'état d'esprit
est là c'est c'est eh
l'un des fondements sur lesquels on va
s'appuyer état d'esprit et aujourd'hui
on a eu l'état d'esprit et puis on a eu
on a eu un peu de volume de jeu donc on
est on est très satisfait pierre
chevallier une réaction par rapport à ce
début de saison prometteur pas tellement
surpris on parlait on parlait fusion en
fin de saison précédente
et justement des avantages et des
inconvénients s'est débloquée en fin de
saison 1 vers moi tu vois on en parlait
déjà
ce sont deux clubs qu'on connaît bien et
déjà notamment des bons clubs des
yvelines des bons clubs formateurs avec
des des bons mecs à tous les étages que
ce soit les joueurs ou le staff il ya
des infrastructures il ya une volonté
maintenant des deux de tirer profit
entre guillemets 2d des difficultés que
connaît le rugby amateur en ce moment à
la fois en termes de nombre de licenciés
dans les écoles de rugby ou au niveau
senior on va parler des règles des
nouvelles règles d'arbitrage qui joue
quand même là dessus et battu les pumas
cela vous avez des gens qui vont vouloir
prendre une licence donc pas surpris de
les voir bien démarré sûrement trop tôt
pour pouvoir tirer des plans sur la
comète et puis
faire des conclusions sur le reste de la
saison mais mais en tout cas c'est très
bien pour eux ça fait un club de plus
solide dans les yvelines c'est une bonne
chose
je rappelle que mon team retenu était en
promotion honneur et le sky rugby était
temps honneur chez les seniors une
réaction gens par rapport à cette
première victoire
vous êtes de la vie de pierre chevalier
oui oui tout à fait tout à fait on sait
que les deux clubs avec des difficultés
de d'effectifs et le fait d'avoir
fusionné baisse alors donne ça leur
donne un élan elle est là quand on sait
que de plus en plus il est plus en plus
difficile pour les clubs
on le voit là cette année à l'honneur il
ya pas mal de clubs qui ont de grosses
difficultés à a présenté l'équipe
réserve
dire qu'ils ont un effectif senior qui
est qui qui est très très limité donc le
fait de fusionner comme ça de deux clubs
ça permet de redonner une dynamique à
l'effectif est de pouvoir envisager une
belle saison c'est ce qui commence à
faire très très bien puisque en plus
apparemment d'après les commentaires il
ya non seulement la réussite et la
victoire même plus il ya la manière
donc c'est tout à fait positif et
encourageant pour la suite cette équipe
la question sur ce thème est-ce qu'il
faut pousser les clubs à s'allier oui ou
non les clubs locaux bien sûr fait
partager vous êtes tous partagent
moi je dirais non parce que parce que
c'est pas normal que aujourd'hui on
n'arrive pas aujourd'hui où tous ont dit
qu'il faut faire du sport qu'il faut
faire ben qu'il faut se bouger parce que
parce qu'on a tous des métiers
sédentaires et que consent grâce qu'on
sent grèce
je trouve pas ça normal que des des
sports n'arrive pas à des clubs
n'arrivent pas à avoir assez de
d'adhérents pour pouvoir
fournir des équipes pour pouvoir être
être sur les sur les sur les terrains
donc pour moi c'est ce serait non
maintenant aujourd'hui en effet vu
l'état d'esprit des de la population on
n'a pas le choix
pour pouvoir répondre aux besoins de
ceux qui souhaitent participer donc la
fosse conséquente aux conséquences je
trouve ça moi je suis je suis
entièrement d'accord et ça que je trouve
ça je trouve ça dommage c'est pas c'est
pas seulement pour le rugby c'est pour
ces dans tous les sports
j'ai des enfants qui sont qu'ils sont
jeunes cons le combi temps et on voit
bien que arriver à une quinzaine
d'années eh bien il ya une baisse
d'effectifs qui a été phénoménal alors
est-ce que c'est dû à cause des études
et jeu et je suis sûr que c'est pas
c'est une fois c'est une exclusivité
d'exclusive ça les études parce que j'ai
connu des athlètes de haut niveau qui
compte qu'ils continuent leur leurs
études leurs études à côté et qui
arrivait à allier les deux et souvent
quand on a la discipline du sport et
bien et du coup on arrive à trouver
l'équilibré pour pouvoir travailler à
l'école et avoir de bons résultats
scolaires
moi je me souviens d'un copain avec qui
j'ai commencé à faire du vélo en même
temps
il quand ils coururent nationale il
était en école de l'école de kiné la
seule école de kiné pour être qu'il est
libéral et pour être et qui est une
école gratuite
et voilà s'il avait réussi concours
d'entrée pour pouvoir avoir accès à
cette seule école qui existe en france
et donc il ce mec-là couru en national
il a couru en 1re caté en vélo et voilà
il arrivait à faire les deux alors ce
sont des métiers qui sont qui sont très
compliqués des études qui sont très
longues
donc faut pas se voiler la face derrière
derrière d écrire je vais vous donner la
parole hélène qu'est-ce que vous qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
je pense que pour le fait de fusionner
on n'en tient pas vraiment les les
catégories de d'adhérents matière
maintient pas aussi les différentes
disciplines comme elles doivent après
c'est une question d'effectifs sur sur
des catégories d'âge peut-être sur
certaines périodes mais il y avait un
problème d'effectif il n'avait pas assez
de deux joueurs tout simplement pour
être compétitif en mon honneur et c'est
pareil pour la promotion je pense que
c'est les seuls
un des seul argument qui peut la
justifier une fusion mais sinon on a pu
faire plusieurs raisons financières et
la fusion de deux clubs
quelquefois pour des raisons financières
et pour pouvoir monter un projet ça on
le voit plus sur le côté professionnel
après au niveau amateur il a raison d'un
effectif ça c'est ce qui touche le sky
et montigny et qu'avec les cas mener
cette fusion est ensuite après sur tous
les secteurs
c'est ce qu'ont laissé les obscénités
aux équipes seniors de récoler rugby
voile à l'école de rugby est également
les jeunes et les films tellement et la
troisième raison de ces sportifs parce
que souvent c'est arrivé au stade
français par exemple où le stade
français à l'époque est montée en
première division grâce aux singes et
parce que sportivement le stade français
n'arrivais pas à monter à l'échelon
supérieur avant de connaître la carrière
du club mais ils sont montés à l'échelon
supérieur
grâce à une fusion avec le cg qui
aujourd'hui n'existe plus et qui est
d'ailleurs propriétaire enfin qui était
propriétaire du stade jean bouin
mais voilà donc il ya plusieurs raisons
de fusion là c'est là c'est dur
effectifs question c'est la différence
entre justement la cause et et les
conséquences si si on regarde uniquement
les conséquences oui il faut pousser les
il faut pousser les clubs à s'allier
parce que jean a cité les différentes
raisons j'en ajouterai une autre qui est
celle de l'encadrement des accrocs ont
fait des économies d'échelle et puis on
dionne un petit peu tous les staffs là
effectivement ça concerne pas toutes les
catégories mais en tout cas on prend les
on prend les forces là où elles sont
dans l'un et l'autre des clubs on
fusionne tout ça et ça donne ça donne un
effet positif
ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut avec surtout
photo cor dans le cadre de l effectif
plus fourni qui permet justement de
s'aligner sur une compétition mais là je
le vois sur donc sur le sur le
département des yvelines avec les coques
que je connais bien et il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de constats difficultés là et
qui n'arrivent pas à aligner par exemple
deux équipes seniors en honneur
promotion honneur par exemple je pense
au rugby club chez les ja la celle saint
cloud qui ont qui ont été contraints de
mettre une équipe une équipe réserve en
loisir en fait finalement et les causes
c'est un petit peu là le désamour du
rugby chez les plus jeunes pour
l'instant on espère qu'un effet positif
coupe du monde
d'ici là fin novembre enfin d'ici début
novembre finale de la coupe du monde
mais c'est elles sont plus là les
raisons dont les raisons aller chercher
des explications
hélas là c'est pas des bons signes donc
répondre à cette question pousser les
clubs à s'allier non parce que c'est
c'est malheureusement c'est un scénario
qui n'est pas bon qui est qui qui est
une perte de vitesse de du rugby et de
la pratique du rugby dans les clubs
puisque là on parle de rugby mais ça ça
concerne sûrement plein d'autres sports
et c'est là dessus qu'il faut bosser et
sert sur l'image positive sur la
sécurité des joueurs sur le plaisir la
bande de copains sur ces fameuses
valeurs de l'ovalie qui continuent elles
à faire les beaux jours de beaucoup de
clubs et est justement éviter que des
clubs sont en difficulté et soit
contraint de s'allier versailles
pourrait fusionner un jour avec par
exemple je vis le club de du siège à
tenir on ne peut jamais dire
c'est à dire qu'après si ça permet de
régler un des problèmes qu'on a cité
avec jean ii d'effectifs de problèmes
financiers ou au contraire d'aller
chercher un projet un projet sportif un
petit peu plus ambitieux et que ça
correspond surtout aussi un besoin de
l'autre club
pourquoi pas là actuellement
actuellement c'est pas sympa j'ai pas à
l'ordre du jour mais mais jamais dire
jamais je vais faire un petit tour de
table avant de refermer cette thématique
une réaction par rapport au nouveau nom
de l'équipe union rugby 178 je me sens
perdue dans trop long ça vous fera
hélène fonctionnement le centre 78 870
vite aux régions et départements
virulence entre la déportance et pouvoir
faire lui verser 60 18 août la base là
ça peut marcher
après sur le centre géographique c'est
peu on va voir dans jean zay aucun avis
c'est parce qu'il va à la voir passer
maintenant notre rubrique focus
on continue par du rugby une petite
révolution dans le milieu amateur
désormais il faudra faire attention aux
plaquages à partir de cette saison la
fédération française a décidé de changer
les règles désormais la ligue la ligue
de plaquages situe en dessous des
épaules et abc il faut a désormais
plaqués en dessous de la taille interdit
également de plaquer à deux joueurs en
même temps
et l'attaquant n'a plus le droit d'aller
percuter les défenseurs la tête baissée
objectif lutter contre les commotions
cérébrales et les chocs à la tête
autre objectif empêcher les défenseurs
de bloquer les bras de l'attaquant la
question on voit justement des séquences
de jeu avec larbi qui sanctionne voilà
en voile le ralenti la gastro
c'est la sanction la question sur ce
thème
est ce que c'est une bonne initiative
oui ou non
oui non vous votez pas biya laisse la
place aux spécialistes parce que ce que
s'il faut aimer le plateau je l'espère
vous maîtrisez pas les bacs avec moi
élèves mais on fait un petit duel avec
pierre vu que yann n'a pas d'avis je
pense que c'est pas forcément un petit
duel c'est juste que on connaît les
blessures qu'il ya moi je connais
personnellement quelqu'un qui a une idée
sur importante suite justement claquage
ben en fait et on voit les répercussions
que cela peut avoir
après
donc je pense que c'est au niveau santé
c'est quand même peut-être moins pire
maintenant pour que tout le monde joue
comme ça avec cette nouvelle
une nouvelle règle là je sais pas
comment fin serait de prendre un sacré
bout de temps parce que les techniques
les tactiques et tout ça sont finalement
tellement ancré dans rubik modifier ça
je pense que il va y avoir de la faute à
mon avis pierre chevallier jeudi n'ont
volontairement polémique parce que c'est
c'est en fait surtout pour une raison de
deux mises en oeuvre ça n'a pas été
organisée ça a été une réaction en fait
ça a été sûr du point
une réaction est plus que de
l'anticipation on sait depuis longtemps
qu'il ya des problèmes des problèmes
physiques et marmande aux commotions et
même on a parlé d'incidents et
d'accidents tragiques et mortelle
l'année dernière il ya eu des morts
finalement les milanais un joueur de 23
ans est décédé à l'hôpital de dijon il
avait subi un choc 45 jours plus tôt là
et c'est déjà ça il ya un jeune un jeune
espoir du stade français aussi qui est
décédé sur le terrain ça c'est
dramatique
il faut remonter un petit peu aux
sources aux sources du jeu et se dire
que depuis depuis 95 depuis que le rugby
est professionnel
c'est là un peu la course à l'armement
c'est la course à la musculation cetc
des autobus qu'on s'envoie les uns sur
les autres et maintenant on est passé
d'un sport d'évitement un sport de n'ont
plus de contacts mais de collisions
c'est à dire vraiment vraiment de
fracassage il faut il faut mettre
l'adversaire sur le cul passez moi
l'expression mais c'est un peu ça et on
en est là actuellement à essayer de
protéger les maintenant les joueurs pas
ce genre de mesures sauf que ça a été
pris fin de saison dernière au coeur de
l'été et puis à ben et puis appliquer
directement et est imposé aux différents
clubs comme tu disais laine je peux vous
assurer qu effectivement sur les
terrains notamment les villes de terrain
francilien ce que j'ai vu c'est un c'est
un bazar sans nom parce que tout est
soumis à l'interprétation de l'arbitré
et surtout surtout c'était en fait il
faut rééduquer tous les joueurs alors
pas les joueurs des côtes de rugby pour
qui pour qui pour la plupart dans tous
les clubs
après la plaque et aux jambes ça c'est
ainsi qu'une base donc à faire tomber
l'adversaire qu'ils soient petits qu'ils
soient grands ans le jour
prenons par les jambes mais parce qu'on
était on était arrivé à un rugby un
rubis tellement tellement physique qu'on
coffret l'on ferait le ballon sur le sur
le torse et qu'on faisait vraiment du
placage haut sans faire tomber le joueur
il fallait bloquer le joueur y est pas
le faire tomber
donc là moi ce que je ce que je condamne
ou dénonce avec avec un avec un qui
avait fait un carton rouge
c'est dire que ça a été mal préparé et
que désormais oui il va falloir il va
falloir un peu de temps pour que ça soit
qui est un bien pratiqué et que les
arbitres puissent arriver à s'en sortir
ce que là on a on a une dizaine une
quinzaine de pénalités par match parce
que il faut réhabituer les joueurs à
pâques et aux jambes
on va donner la parole à yann wehrling
s'est jamais fait plaquer si si moi j'ai
quand même une question parce que dira
plaques et aux jambes
un genou en actions qui rencontre une
tête je suis pas sûr que la tête soit
vainqueur première première juin et puis
deuxième chose pour alors est-ce que les
casques que l'on peut voir c'est certain
rythme professionnel ont un vrai une
vraie utilité
on est donc dans ces cas là pourquoi ne
pas les rendre obligatoires chez une
poêle américain par ailleurs je parle de
thua certains traumato qui disent que en
fait ça certains présentent certains
avantages comme ça mais d'un autre côté
ça n'empêche pas la commission veut dire
que c'est un choc à la tête
avec ou sans casque ton cerveau bouge
donc à commotion donc il faut pas il
faut pas que le que le casque soit là il
ya fort à meylan voilà j'ai eu quand
comme je vous entends fin quand je
réfléchis un tout petit peu je me dis
plaques et aux jambes je veux bien mais
un genou métis prend un jaune dans le
petit fou qui se le prend mal placé au
niveau d'attentes
je pense qu'il va résonner ça va
résonner un peu fort quand même genre
moi ce cette règle là c'est une voie là
c'est une règle on fait beaucoup de
règles actuellement
sous sous sous la protection du joueur
quand protection du joueur
liane viens de le dire je suis pas
certain que des blessures au niveau de
la commotion des commotions cérébrales
avec des placages d'un projet en année -
mois pour moi n'aura plus cinq cas les
chercher en eau
le braquage a mal sauf que sur ce que
tactiquement ce que vous avez oublié de
préciser c'est non seulement maintenant
il faut plaquer en dessous de la
ceinture au niveau moteur mais que le
plaquage à deux joueurs est interdite
voilà c'est à deux aussi les deux y
avait également le placage en dessous de
la ceinture mais à deux joueurs et
pendant des années en tant qu'entraîneur
on a travaillé quand même le plaquage à
deux c'est à dire un en bas et un petit
bloc en eau pour la continuité de jeu
donc c'est il ya déjà tout une toute une
habitude a changé à rechange et offrait
des joueurs donc la formation
ensuite on parle on parle de la sécurité
du joueur sauf que on pose ça et puis de
l'autre côté au niveau honneur par
exemple on fait reprendre le championnat
quelques jours avant donc le 22
septembre
sachant que les gens ont une reprise
d'entraînement à ce niveau la fin août
c'est à dire qu'ils ont quelques jours
d'entraînement avant la reprise du
championnat et vous démarrez avec quatre
matchs d'affilée quatre dimanches de
suite où vous avez des matchs donc
quatre quatre d'affilée avec une
majoration forcément avant ses cinq
matches d'affilée à ce niveau là avec
des joueurs que la préparation de dix
jours et après on vous parle de sécurité
du joueur
et après vous restez un mois c'est le
joueur qui devient dangereux
non mais à ce niveau là les joueurs sont
pas préparés physiquement parce que
c'est pas des pros de que l'été il les
passe tactiquement la formation elle
n'est pas du tout donc là on a des
débuts de matchs qui sont
catastrophiques
et puis à l'interprétation de l'arbitré
énorme parce que ce fameux plaquage à 2
lorsque là par contre la sécurité pour
moi est lié lorsque deux joueurs
prennent un joueur en bas en bas je dis
pas comme joueur le placage en au hockey
mais deux joueurs qui plaquent un joueur
en bas là il ya de la sécurité là il ya
la sécurité joueurs et ça on l'interdît
aussi sauf que tu es et on a un cas
pratique sur la première journée du rc
versailles à l'extérieur où tu es 2 à 2
2 les deux défenseurs qui se qui se tape
la tête ouais mais bon média d un sommet
le soutien des états non mérité le
risque le risque zéro n'existe pas de
toute façon le risque zéro n'existe pas
et qu qui quoique quelques règles comme
met en place il y aura toujours des
accidents forcément alors plus ou moins
on n'en sait rien mais là la mise en
place est trop rapide
et puis donc l'adaptation va être un
petit peu longue la part des arbitres
des joueurs et après franchement niveau
commotion je suis pas convaincu la
préparation physique finalement c'est
pas là je pense que c'est même pas la
même en fait parce que finalement ça se
jouera pas vraiment pareil en algérie à
aller vous avez su déjouer la base à 10
cm la savate interprétation aussi sur
leur a sué sur les remparts finalement
on repart qu'un sur du rugby d'antan
avec du placage haut jamais à 1 contre
st revient à l'essence on revient les
sages du rugby d'un côté sauf que depuis
des années on a en
on a travaillé sur sur le physique du
joueur pour qu'il soit le plus en plus
performants donc qui dit joueur de rugby
plus performants 10 - de l'espace sur le
terrain de kembs qui est moins d'espacé
plus de contacts et plus de 2,2 de
combat forcément l'intention est louable
très rapidement fier l'attention sur les
malheureux mise en oeuvre daniel la mise
en eau ne sut pas et simplifier je n'ai
pas l'action complètement des pannes de
jeu et ses jours les fans de jeux
actuels alliés son dernier mot coupe du
monde s'est impliqué dans les pros sur
les détend pas sa passion j'ai bien aimé
la photo des sud africains à savoir
changer on va passer à notre prochain
sujet à pied à présent thomas d'eric a
réalisé son rêve cet été ce jeune qui
monte un de 20 ans a traversé en totale
autonomie pendant six jours le salar
d'uyuni le plus grand désert de sel au
monde il a filmé son aventure à l'aide
d'une caméra regardé et on commente
juste après
[Applaudissements]
je m'apprête à partir et là c'est réel
c'est concret parce qu'une fois que je
serai là dedans je fais tout seul en
totale autonomie sans gps sans tracker
sans balises sans téléphone satellite
aucun moyen de contacter le reste du
monde donc il y aura que moi et le vide
ça fait quelque chose
[Musique]
agca pour cet après midi jusqu'à ce que
je pose mon temps ce soir et après j'ai
une deuxième lourde pour visionner ce
soir et pour la soit passé au rite parce
que j'ai vraiment très très chaud y'a
aucun espace dhombres j'ai soif et je
peux pas boire plus que que mes réserves
tu peux pas tout voir là d'un coup j'ai
obligé de me restreindre
et là j'ai soif
là c'est vraiment dur
à part la fatigue et l'énervement un peu
de la journée parce que ça a été dur
j'ai quand même super content d'être là
j'ai aucun regret c'est un lieu
incroyable et ça fait partie des choses
que je vais pas vivre tous les jours
dans ma vie donc faux
je profite de cet instant ici je vois
rien autour de moi je crois que je viens
de là bas mais je suis pas totalement
sûr je te garder ce cap
ok
[Musique]
je veux vérifier mon cap tous les 100
mètres et tous les 100 mètres je m'en
rends compte qu'en fait tu t'es en train
de dévier et que je dois changer de
direction du marché avec la boussole
dans la main après c'est compliqué
[Musique]
l'extrême sais pas comment j'ai fait
pour 188 sont là dedans mais j'ai réussi
ça brûle en attente
par contre ces extrêmes c'est sûr ça va
être vraiment nui extrême
attentats les accrocher avait un
de poche à eau et à mon sac de l'autre
côté
et voilà
[Musique]
voilà donc le désert ça trouve ici et je
ne suis plus dedans je suis enfin sorti
du salar d'uyuni j'ai rejoint la terre
les cailloux ça sort sur autre chose que
sur du sel parce que j'en avais marre
d'avoir les fesses toutes blanches à
cause de ça donc voilà c'est la fin de
cette aventure
après 140 km parcouru six jours de
solitude donc des airs de 30 kg d'andré
connu par deux côtés une moyenne de 23
kilomètres par jour parcouru ce désert
[Musique]
hellemmes une réaction et moi je fais
quand même je suis quand même fier
j'avais remis jeudi
il part à l'aventuré il se prépare comme
il peut il est plutôt comment dire
décider
courageux il part sur un sur un trajet
qui fait en même pas une semaine donc
quand il voit quand même le bout du
tunnel il ya quand même de quoi devenir
fou sinon mais non je suis quand même
comment dire ont impressionné que enfin
contente pour lui qu'il est qu'il
réussit son petit périple
parce que je pense qu'il y avait je vais
pleurer franchement je vais tous ces
noms mais je pense que il ya vraiment
moyen de devenir fou avec un paysage
qu'ils changent jamais dans l'adversité
entre le 15 degrés le moins 5 la chaleur
le froid le vent personnes il a dû
parler beaucoup tout seul il ya ces
caméras
ian fry
oui je juste un truc je trouve dommage
qu'il n'ait pas vu voulu quand même
prendre une
une puce gps juste pour pouvoir retracer
le parcours qu'il a acquis là qu'il a
établi ensuite parce que en effet sur la
carte on voit une ligne droite
aujourd'hui on peut juste dire une chose
et qu'il est relâché à garder le cap
mais comme il le dit tout laisse tous
les 100 mètres il a dû rectifier à
certains moments surtout quand elle
était alors la tempête
voilà et donc il nous aurait pu être
intéressant justement quand même de
pouvoir voir ensuite comment il avait
réussi à traverser ce désert sinon après
ben ouais six joueurs de promenade sympa
quoi genre vous avez été captivés vous
parle quelles étaient ses motivations ce
garçon il voulait se retrouver seul dans
le désert a ouai c'est toi tu reviennes
j'ai vu que je lui connais quelqu'un qui
veut lui faire faire un tour du
catamaran vous êtes vous rêviez
j'attends avec et oui non mais c'est
bien voilà c'est une belle performance
et voit la belle performance vient de le
dire belle performance plus quel jeu
joue sans taquin ses courses mais non
mais je fais je félicite à après web et
pourquoi pas à quoi pierre qui reste peu
de terrain de jeu en fait vierge de ce
côté là et peu d' aventure que d'
aventure originale nouvelle ce qu'il ya
un certain nombre de choses qui ont été
quand on était tenté depuis depuis de
longue date par l'homme et la femme et
je pense à la les grandes courses au
large par exemple est vraiment laid les
aventures d'aventuriers pour rappeler
aux nas mais avec un avec la un vrai
défi je pense que c'est un défi pour lui
seul je pense pas qu'on soit très
nombreux à en parler malgré eux
malheureusement et malheureusement pour
lui mais c'est a priori un défi pour lui
même de suite c'est d'être seul de
vouloir être seul il aurait pu aller
peut-être en forêt de rambouillet
peut-être qu'il aurait peut-être été
plus seul il ya peut-être de plus
d'animaux mais en tout cas c'est une
c'est une belle aventure
il va au bout il a dû se préparer quand
même un minimum pour y arriver il ya
suffisamment peu de
deux défis de ce type là tenté et réussi
pour ne pas se passerait joueur pour lui
quelles que soient les raisons de sa
motivation
je leur fais vraiment aucun contact avec
personne il a seulement 20 ans donc il
part dans un pays étranger donc ils
cumulent des petites des petits
challenge comme ça moi je serais
intéressé de savoir s'il va vouloir
préparer d'autres voilà d'autres trucs
déjà commencé trois destinations
intérieures et puisse préparer vraiment
bien sûr ça tu es sûr c'est d'ailleurs
bien du sel je pense qu'on regarde en
stick la vue des tempêtes des sols en
tout cas encore bravo à thomas d'eric on
va maintenant parler de cyclisme deux
nouvelles ont provoqué un petit séisme
sur la piste de tête d'affiche laurie
berton et sandie clair ont décidé
d'arrêter un an vont les jeux olympiques
de tokyo
laurie à berton médaille d'argent de
l'omnium aux mondiaux de londres en 2016
a déclaré ne plus éprouver de plaisir
sur un vélo de son côté 110 claire
évoque un problème avec la fédération
qui a décidé d'arrêter la vitesse par
équipes dames la fédération ne lui
accorderait plus sa confiance pour une
médaille
je rappelle que les deux athlètes
s'entraîner au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la question
sur ce thème ces décisions sont elles
compréhensible oui ou non on va
commencer déjà par laurie laurie berton
qui s'arrête après pascal est plus
motivé je suis allé le voir
oui on comprend c'est son choix
voulez-vous de plus si si si mais c'est
difficile difficile c'est un choix
personnel grands noms choix personnel
vous aller vous allez faire des projets
de vie je suis scandalisé oui après
chacun faire à l'école elle est quand
même assez jeune à la 28 ans de vie
différent mais des choisi celle de haut
niveau ont discuté de l'épousé l'été sur
bhv qui voit plusieurs villes où que ce
soit voilà le prends plus de plaisir
mackenzie et poursuit pascal robin haase
elles n'ont jamais voulu enchaîner alors
laurie fleury était vice championne du
monde de dominium l'omnium ancienne
formule
c'est à dire que c'était il y avait plus
d'épreuves c'était l'été sur deux jours
un peu comme les tacles ou en athlétisme
et là et sur la nouvelle formule ça ne
se fasse plus que sur une seule journée
et ils ont enlevé les deux épreuves de
sprint qui étaient les plus favorables à
l'horizon puisque laurie est une
ancienne sprinteuse et c'est vrai que l
a essayé de rebondir en se mettant la
poursuite par équipes elle a essayé
aussi avec l'américaine mais elle m'a
dit c'est vrai que je ne prenais plus de
plaisir et les nouveaux de chalenge
n'ont pas de nom pas fait vibrer plus
que ça et puis en effet 27 enfin à 27 28
ans laurie se dit que c'est maintenant
si elle veut pouvoir faire une
reconversion parce que donc elle est là
un nouveau challenge avec avec la fdj
dans la dans la communication pour
pouvoir justement de prendre du temps de
se former et de pouvoir ensuite avoir un
nouveau métier afin un métier un métier
ensuite c'est vrai que les pistards
c'est c'est les parents pauvres du
cyclisme info il faut pas le faut pas le
cacher et donc bah ils ont tous
rapid arrêts tous pensent rapidement à
leur reconversion ensuite voilà la lorie
a une opportunité je pense qu'elle a
elle fait bien de le faire et surtout
quand on est un sportif de haut niveau
quelle que soit la discipline à partir
du moment où on prend du plaisir c'est
difficile d'aller à l'entraînement tout
simplement donc vos rêves bien sûr il
faut arrêter et donc je pense qu'ils en
effet il était temps et c'est vrai que
les résultats que l'on pouvait avoir par
rapport à ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle
avait pu avoir un grand tokyo s'est pas
à lloret pas pu faire tokyo faire tokyo
pour quoi faire faire tokyo pour y aller
pour y aller pour le voyage sais pas ce
qui s'est passé à qui la motive
loris et laurie le rire à tokyo parce
que quentin sera à tokyo avec la vitesse
par équipes donc élire à tokyo elle fera
le voyage dans le canton afin d'être
intéressant compagnon mai
mais c'est vrai que
et sympa même voyage je pense non mais
elle va vibrer est la libérer elle vibre
aujourd'hui sur les résultats de parler
les attentats alors quand on quand on
est les champions
quand on est champion du monde du
kilomètre et je pense qu'aujourd'hui bas
elle vit son rêve olympique et son rêve
de médaillé olympique travers au travers
de quentin et donc tout tout tout va
bien mais voilà je pense que en effet
pour pour norris était bon mais j'avais
peur comme j'ai vu l'annoncent delory
sur les réseaux sociaux que ce soit
quelque chose de ne pas n'est ce pas
décidé et on est en en discutant avec
elle j'ai vraiment compris que voilà
c'était elle qui allait présenter en
mairie c'était vraiment réfléchi voilà
on va revenir à 110 clair est-ce que
vous comprenez sa décision c'est un sa
décision la force et que l'alors alors
continuer mais bien sûr bien sûr 110 et
c'est la mort dans l'âme c'est déjà
depuis depuis depuis rio elle a été elle
a été mis à l'écart est un peu plus
vieille déjà aussi elle avait 31 ans
dont elle était plus en fin de carrière
il reste un jeu vous jouez encore donner
un exemple christophe a été champion
olympique à 34 ans voilà champion
olympique du keirin
à 31 ans au sprint on n'est pas mort je
suis désolé mais depuis rio on a mis des
bâtons dans les roues à 110 c'est à dire
qu'il y avait eu les mauvais résultats
de l'équipe de l'équipe des garçons
eh bien on a mis à de côté 110 alors que
elle n'avait pas fait de vagues pendant
pendant les pendant les jeux de rio
elle a été mis à l'écart elle s'est
entraîné avec son frère tout seul à
ayherre pour pouvoir revenir je ne sait
plus sur quel championnat de france où
elle est devenue championne de france en
battant mathilde de gros et donc du coup
l air
venu en équipe de france elle a mis un
an et demi ou deux ans pour pouvoir
rubber reprendre son son sa place dans
l'équipe de france elle continue de
s'entraîner avec son coude avec son
frère attention elle n'était pas à 100%
elle était pas tout le temps à saint
quentin en yvelines est aujourd'hui à un
an des jeux on lui dit au revoir au
revoir et pour des raisons alors que
alors que voilà on a quand on en discute
entre nous on n'a vraiment pas
l'impression que l'équipe de france ait
donné dans attali je finis on avait
l'équipe de france et donné tous les
moyens à ce duo de performer voilà
redonner la parole un peu aux autres
c'est que vous êtes passionné par le
sujet hellemmes
c'est surtout qu'on supprime des
disciplines qui elle qui est là pour le
coup il pensait clairement pina et qui
n'auraient pas de médailles avec sept
avec ces disciplines
et oui mais non aux jeux olympiques je
regarde avec des médailles je me pose la
question on a fait des c est ce que 100%
de nos athlètes toutes disciplines
confondues reviennent avec des médailles
djo et bien non on n'y avait plus de 400
athlètes tous les ans et on revient pas
mais 400 médaille et je ne suis pas allé
beaucoup aimé vous êtes passionné par le
sujet jean oui non oui
non mais c'est bien parce que j'écoute
ce que dit yann et c'est vrai que moins
il est ici connaît et c'est dommage pour
sportivement je dis que c'est dommage de
priver de privé de jeux olympiques
un sportif de haut niveau quel qu'il
soit c'est une sportive en l'occurrence
là haut niveau quelles qu'elles soient a
assisté à un an de l'échéance
voilà c'est terminé quatrième des
derniers jeux auraient plan européen en
kaelin voilà donc venons mais si c'est
regrettable
c'est regrettable honnêtement sur le
thème quelles que soient ses résultats
et ils sont bons en plus sont pas non
mais c'est là je je je comprends la
colère maintenant que j'ai compris le
sujet je comprends la colère
alors puissant mais sans lui c'est une
athlète qui est adorable voilà une
gamine qui est un peu quelques
thématiques etc etc ou des mines timide
qui voilà qui est un peu réservé et mais
par contre qui est investi à 200 % dans
son sport c'est pas de quoi pas aux plus
de 100 %
ça n'existe pas et va aller voir la
fédération française de cyclisme et
rodin au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en décider ils sont bornés je
rappelle que la piste féminine française
attend toujours sa première médaille
olympique depuis lors de félicia
ballanger à sydney en 2000
on passe maintenant notre page des bas
dans cette page débat nous allons parler
de golf l'open de france l'un des plus
vieux tournoi continental sera organisé
du 17 au 20 octobre sur le golf national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines une date
inhabituelle le tournoi était organisé
jusque la fin juin mais l'european tour
a décidé de déplacer la date
le temps sera sûrement moins radieux au
niveau du plateau des joueurs des
joueurs seuls les français et le
vainqueur 2018 alex north end le suédois
seront présents la dotation est passé de
7 à moins de 3 millions d'euros de
dotation la question sur ce thème
faut-il être inquiet pour l'open de
france de golf 2019 oui j'en rends bien
sûr bien sûr quand on voit le témoin le
plateau et puis même et ça passe de 7 à
3 c'est pas une claque la comprend
il n'y a personne de 3 -2 3 à -2 3 donc
la moitié se sauve bien ça veut dire si
sa défense
voilà ça n'intéresse personne
je pas non plus voilà j'ai pas non plus
trop noircir le tableau mais quand même
les chiffres sont là c'est dommage et
certains la date est une des principales
à raison de 2,7
lundi dernier tournoi de l'année oui
mais en plus on est quand même sur du mi
octobre mi octobre entre mi octobre et
juin et pas photo ouais donc là c'est un
petit peu inquiétant qu'un pour ce alors
c'est un petit peu dommage pour moi par
rapport à ce que ce qu'est ce qu'on
était capable de faire sur la dernière
ryder cup et que on or si c'est un petit
peu le tableau du golfe pour arrêter
2009 nationale et qu'on or si c'est un
petit peu le tableau du golf français
avec avec cette décision qui à mon avis
va faire redescendre un petit peu la
popularité du golf aux yeux de tout le
monde c'est une sacré talent est là on
est à un an jour pour jour de la ryder
cup qui a été un succès incontestable et
incontesté d'ailleurs la la la l'édition
ryder cup qui a été la plus rentable de
l'histoire en france qui a été un
fantastique événement populaire on en a
on en a suffisamment parlé sur ce
plateau et dans les différentes
émissions et là on a une sensation de
gueule de bois monumentale
tout parent a priori de l'european tour
qui a organisé un petit peu les choses
comme ça à partir du 2 en 2 ans en amont
de la ryder cup avec l'arrivée d'un
sponsor à chesnais qui qui fait monter
le locateur sont rationnées qui a rompu
son contrat
là c'était exactement trois ans et qui
finalement c est parti au bout de au
bout de deux ans en fait c'était
simplement l'impact de la ryder cup l
attrait de la ryder cup est fière parti
à parti un nom trop tôt et financier
également oui au local il y avait de
gros soucis financiers au niveau mondial
de ceux de cet avionneur chinois mais on
a on est passé on est passé d'un statut
de rolex est risqué en gaule
la rolls des tournois de golf au niveau
mondial qui attire les plus grands
joueurs de la planète avec une dotation
est une date qui est qui qui fait date
justement derrière c'est le sait l'open
d'espagne à valderrama qui a pris la
place de l'open de france sur leur fin
juin début juillet l'open de france
relégués relayée en octobre maintenant
avec une dotation qui est plus proche
des 1 million 5 des trois d'ailleurs et
un plateau qui est absolument désertique
on espère on espère qu'on aura beaucoup
de français et que pour le coup sûr lors
sur leur terrain et avec un terrain qui
est désormais mondialement connu et puis
ce qu'ils puissent émerger et briller on
a on a nos reines qui sera là on à olten
qui devait être là mais qui tombe sur
des problèmes privés sur les toits sur
des questions privées qui finalement ne
pourra pas tenir son engagement de
harcèlement moral dont il était suspendu
par le fait pas on revient on voit les
images de mettre la tête d'affiché avec
ardeur on n'a plus qu'un petit but donc
c'est vraiment malheureux
oui on peut être inquiet parce que
effectivement la date que ce soit pour
le spectacle pour le jeu pour les
les spectateurs et pour tout ce qu'on
peut faire avec les avec les partenaires
en loge et autres ça va ça va /
l'occurrence par trois ou quatre comme
la dotation l'affluence qui peut y avoir
au golf national alors que c'est un
fantastique stadium pour le golf
souhaitons malgré tout que l'on puisse
reprendre vie que le développement des
licenciés en france la fédé oeuvre pour
ça mais ça donne après les révisions
française de déplacer la date peut-être
de l'open de france également oui oui
oui mais pas mais au moins 70 patients
ont débuté leur passion octobre malgré
tout pour avoir la chanson ils ont
permis à la chance de ne pas pleuvoir
mais mais ça sera de toute façon moins
agréable que fin juin début juillet même
s'il a fait très très chaud les
dernières années ces dommages peuvent la
colombe et des joints espagne c'est pas
du tout à fait pas c'est pas dire que
non c'est pas des guerres non à la on a
que toi ali ramin très bien drainé au
cas où ils peuvent
il n'y a pas de problème de publier une
assurance rationnement oms va répondre
présent solange au nom des deux joueurs
la preuve la preuve en est sa pensée de
passionnés passionnés y aurait bien sûr
mais on promet les passionnés les
passionnés c'est pareil je vois bien
attention on est en région parisienne
les passionnés il leur faut du repos du
plateau je le vois bien d'où avec les
épreuves qui sont qui se déroule à saint
quentin en yvelines quand les plateaux
sont son léger ben il ya moins de monde
on a eu un championnat de france là
cet été où le vélodrome était à plein
mais bien remplie les licenciements le
français qui sont en ile de france donc
on peut espérer qu'il ya un petit peu
plus de monde mais mais sur la période
et le l'engouement qu'il ya autour de
l'évènement ça sera peut-être française
voulait déplacer notamment la date parce
que c'était des départs en vacances fin
juin début juillet y avait beaucoup de
départs en vacances peut-être qu'il y
aura moins de départs en vacances
jamais date idéale sur quelque chose
qu'on n'est pas si vos de la toussaint
que ça mais les gros bras ils ont ils
ont pas eu malheureusement ils n'ont pas
eu trop voix au chapitre sur ce mot sur
au moins sur cette édition 2010 sur la
date de l'audition 2010 mais m
votre mission majeure en ce sens on leur
aurait dit c'est on est en plein dans
penteli qu il n ya pas forcément de deux
meilleures dates
après je pense qu'il faut prendre aussi
les dates où le temps s'y prête et les
les nationals exact où les voilà les
licenciés sont là mais
il donne envie d'y aller vous non non
non mais même moi je suis même pas je
suis pas une licenciée je suis pas une
passionnée et si je me déplace un
événement que je connais pas ou peu je
vais me déplacer parce que je veux vous
non oui mais dans l'idée c'est parce
qu'il ya quelque chose à voir il ya du
monde il ya des grands joueurs pas
seulement un plateau comme la honda leur
genre non parce que finalement il ya
aussi pierre le disait la fédération
française de golf la paye trop trop le
choix sur cette édition
quant à la date je pense aussi est-ce
qu'il n'y aurait pas c'est personnel et
serait pas quand même ces cinq ou les
anglais sont grands
qu'est-ce qui aurait pas quand même une
certaine jalousie par rapport à cet
événement qui acquit ac avait rayonné
sur le monde entier je parle la ryder
cup que nous avons brillamment réussi en
france
est ce que ce n'est pas un côté jaloux
ce tout à fait british la jalousie fair
play le fair play le fameux fair play et
le britannique
donc je pense qu'il y sommes pas et il
n'ya pas étranger à cette angleterre
contacter la régie alors pour
information la billetterie est ouverte
au grand public pour cet open de france
2010 9 c'est la fin cette émission on va
terminer comme d'habitude par une
citation aujourd'hui focus sur une
citation du champion carl lewis si tu
n'as pas confiance tu trouveras toujours
une manière de perdre
je vous laisse méditer sur cette phrase
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]